alguém aqui conseguir ver é quatro
dimensões
já uma vez alguém viu uma hiper fera ou
seja uma esfera quatro dimensões é
exatamente sobre isso que vou falar ou
seja sobre esta nossa incapacidade de
conseguir ver para além de três
dimensões
nós conseguimos imaginar o objeto três
dimensões e duas dimensões mas não
conseguimos o rio de imaginar nada
quatro dimensões seguramente o índice ou
seja passar um preço
quando nós quando estamos matemática
percebemos que do ponto de vista
matemático não há nenhum problema da
passagem das três dimensões para as
quatro dimensões ter um espaço com uma
dimensão e simplesmente ter um espaço
o nosso precisamos de uma cor nada para
definir os pontos deste espaço
normalmente nós pensamos em espaços como
sendo uma reta se nós passarmos propano
e precisamos de duas coordenadas e
chamando em um espaço bidimensional o
espaço de duas dimensões se tivermos
três dimensões é que nós normalmente
identificamos como os passos chamamos o
espaço
nós precisamos de três jornadas para
fazer e determinar a posição de cada
ponto e por isso nós dizemos que o
espaço em três dimensões mas depois não
pára aí nós temos matematicamente
considerar um espaço de quatro dimensões
um espaço onde cada ponto e é definido
por quatro jornadas e prédio em um
espaço onde cada ponto entre por cinco
jornadas cinco dimensões e por ele antes
não há limite matemática para a dimensão
do espaço e todos estes todos estes
passos são importantes e têm implicações
em várias áreas da data do conhecimento
em engenharia tetra e portanto de certa
forma do ponto de vista matemático não
há nada de especial entre as 13 e as
quatro dimensões do ponto de vista de um
métrico a pelo menos para nós
ou seja nós pensarmos nos esperar duas
dimensões é simplesmente na
circunferência é a circunferência eo
conjunto os pontos que dá uma certa
distância de um certo ponto e isso é uma
esfera da conquista bidimensional
se pensarmos no espaço tridimensional
podemos pensar numa esfera uma esfera o
conjunto dos pontos que está uma certa
distância de um certo ponto e se nós
pensarmos em quatro dimensões
matematicamente neste espaço quatro
dimensões filho
podemos considerar a distância entre os
pontos portanto podemos invocar o
conjunto os pontos nos pas quatro
dimensões que está uma certa distância
de um certo ponto isso é uma em perfect
era o espaço é que nós não conseguimos
imaginar eu pelo menos não é e é sobre
isso que os quer falar em herança
tentará é claro um pouco esse problema
eu confesso que não vou dar uma resposta
definitiva esse problema e eu pensei um
bom bocado sobre isso talvez uma meia
hora enquanto e esses sites e é e talvez
possa partilhar convosco algumas idéias
que eu tenho sobre isto e isso talvez
nos ajuda e tornar este problema um
pouco mais claro mas vamos focar um
pouco o problema é sítio
vamos pensar em termos de cores vamos
pensar na forma como nós pressionamos e
couro e o que tem uma imagem ontem as
cores primárias já agora vamos falar do
corpo nós quando estávamos na escola
aprendemos que os cursos podem fazer a
partir das três cores primárias pretende
pedir três corpos primárias nós podemos
formar toda a paleta de cores nós
conhecemos vamos pensar em cortar luz
quando nós temos na escola estamos a
trabalhar com gosto - nós queremos ocian
ôôôô mediante o amaral para essas cores
primárias mas quando nós trabalhamos com
luz por exemplo começou a foto que temos
aqui e quando vamos ver um concerto
nós trabalhamos com outras cores
primárias em particular o ver passa a
ser uma cor primária o vermelho é outra
cor primário usual outra cor primária
todas as cores
em termos luz em terminou há fotos podem
ser feitas a partir destas três cores
primárias ou então babá que mistura
destas estas coisas quando nós cruzamos
ou fotos como está aqui a ser feito no
cruzamento na interseção nós vemos
outras cores basicamente são compostas
pelas duas cores primárias ou pelas três
o ou por várias quantidades dessas cores
primárias a uma forma talvez um pouco
mais uma forma talvez um pouco mais
racional de pensar isto que os índices
normalmente nós na escola pensamos nesta
nova organização dessas cores numa
espécie de rosetta em colocamos os
primários e os culpados e secundárias
especiais etc mas é talvez uma forma um
pouco mais racional pensar isto e pensar
nas cores como vivendo um espaço
tridimensional
o que temos aqui é um espaço
tridimensional mundo entenda isso
eu identifiquei como o corpo temos o
eixo dos demais rodas intensidades de
verdade temos oeste dos verdes e
intensidade dos ventos e temos oeste de
jesus que de ponto de este espaço tem
certas coordenadas nestes que
correspondem uma certa intensidade cada
uma destas cores ou seja pegar até de
ponto este espaço eu possa associar uma
certa cor que é feita exatamente da
mistura dessas doenças dessas
coordenadas com essas intensidades
dito de outra forma queda de pontes paz
corresponde a uma cor que eu consigo
selecionar e que dá cor que eu preciso
pressionar porque eu consigo pressionar
por responder um ponto este passo certa
forma os pas cromático nós conseguimos
imaginar também é tridimensional a
partir de por acaso é que conhecida a
dimensão com nosso espaço físico mas
também é tridimensional
é por isso que nós a nossa
assim é porque é assim porque espaço
tridimensional é tridimensional pela
pela forma como nós somos nós
presenciamos a for a cor da seguinte
forma nós temos um sensor se nos nossos
olhos e temos três tipos sensores e
sensores são sensíveis à luz no espectro
de luz que nós conseguimos ver tão
digamos entre o infravermelha e
ultravioleta ali uns petro nós
conseguimos ver e nós temos três
sensores digamos para simplificar que um
de seus sonhos e sensível outro mais
outro e sensível lozouet outra excessiva
ou ver e quando vem um facebook por
exemplo começou a foto de andré seu a
mim e estou a foto na verdade não é
feito de uma só cor ela é feito várias
várias ondas eletromagnéticas efeito uma
mistura de de ondas eletromagnéticas e e
se essas ondas estimulam cada uma destas
células que eu tenho os olhos com
diferentes intensidades foram focos maio
essencialmente só vai estimular o outro
tipo de célula sensível a vermelho e
essa informação é transmitida no cérebro
e o processo nessa cor como sendo o
vermelho se for outras coisas eu pode
estimular uma combinação destes três
sensores e eu processo nessa cor como
sendo uma certa cor ou seja
o espaço é o fato mas vemos a três
dimensões espaciais e essencialmente
consequência nós temos três tipos
sensores nos nossos olhos
é por isso que nós dizemos sobre ser tri
cutri chromatics ou seja ser que venha
três dimensões cromáticas é maioria dos
humanos são assim os cangurus também são
e as baías
ou seja todos estes erros e os venha
três dimensões cromática eu sou um poeta
de cores que nós conseguimos pressionar
pode ser posta em correspondência com os
pontos de um espaço de três dimensões
mas não tem que ser assim por exemplo
aos de chromatics mamíferos não primatas
humanos daltônicos são dois exemplos e
escassos solução caso de ser só tem dois
tipos de células sensíveis nos olhos
neste caso preuss é as cores primárias
prius são só duas
a partir de duas cores conseguem
construir toda a sua paleta de cores é
claro que eles não vêem tantas coisas
como nós ou dentro de outra forma há
cursos para nossos diferentes preços são
iguais certa forma os passos de cores
que os conseguem pressionar pode ser
colocado no entanto ano eu venho de duas
dimensões cromática seus bens em si
aumento um plano do espaço
tridimensional que nós pessoas normais
com os três sensores conseguimos ver
oque nunca se limita os monocromáticos
eu cá as baías leão marinho e errarmos
humanos mas também a humanos com essa
característica só vem uma dimensão essas
pessoas só vêm essencialmente a preto e
branco é um pouco estranho dizer que é
preto e branco na verdade elas ganham
uma certa coortran eventualmente não pra
ela e pois bem em várias tonalidades
dessa cor
o petróleo é pau é cor que essas pessoas
conseguem distinguir pode ser colocada
numa só dimensão um basicamente numa
reta pode ser pelo teto alugada digamos
numa reta depois aos 30 cromáticos estão
no sistema
no outro extremo está em quatro tipos
sensores para que aqui duas coisas
distintas nós estamos habituados aquela
ideia de certos animais conseguem ver um
espectro mais alargado corso e é verdade
alguns desses animais não só tem mais
tipos
sensores como conseguem ver um espectro
mais alargado mas do que se trata aqui
do que estou a falar aqui eventualmente
os prever num espectro mais alargado tem
só quatro sensores para estes serviços
a paleta de cores correta preuss é um
espaço de quatro dimensões que nós não
conseguimos imaginar justamente pelo
problema que traz aqui ok é de certa
forma e aos do ponto de vista de de
comparados com pessoas normais nós todos
somos daltônicos
ou seja a cores que nós achamos que é
mesma cor que pressa é preciso ser se
não é a mesma cor
este é o caso de répteis pássaros alguns
e alguns insetos
imaginem algumas mulheres recebeu
recentemente que algumas mulheres têm
quatro tipos de sensores
é curioso porque é um pouco por acaso ou
talvez não é verdade é que os genes que
codificam estes tipos sensores nós temos
nos nossos olhos estão no cromossoma x e
como as mulheres têm dois cromossomos x
por alguma razão algumas têm mais
sensores ou seja vocês homens clemente
já passaram por estarem numa loja vossa
é pessoa com quem está aqui é uma mulher
pergunta é qual destas áreas é que tu
gostas mais que vocês pensam comum não
são iguais não provavelmente pra ela não
são iguais
finalmente aos penta chromatics algumas
baías e os pontos também são assim
existem cinco tipos de sensores ou seja
em cinco dimensões é cromáticas e não há
ou não nos conhecem ou 30 animais com
mais dimensões cromáticas mas
teoricamente sim era possível é só ir
adicionando mais sensores sensíveis
outras cores e com isso vai selecionando
sensibilidade é ser certa forma que de
cérebro tem sua dimensão cromática ou
seja cada série está adaptado por o
número de tipos de células sensíveis
acordo nós temos nos nossos olhos certa
forma todos nós somos daltónicos mesmos
pontos porque porque a realidade ainda é
muito mais rica
nós sabemos hoje
que não há forma de com conjunto fini
coros girar toda atleta real do curso
ou seja esta ideia que nós temos com
três cores primárias conseguimos tirar
todas as cores na verdade é uma ilusão
nossa porque nós não conseguimos ver
mais do que isso vamos voltar então
agora estão concentrados aqui que estão
te porque nós não conseguimos ver há
mais dimensões espaciais
eu diria que eu a razão é muito
semelhante estas dimensões cromáticas eu
diria que tal como nosso cérebro está
habituado está preparado para ver uma
certa dimensão cromática também está
preparado para ver uma certa dimensão
especial e isso limita se imaginar
objetos é demais dimensões o que deus
quer mostrar agora e talvez pudesse ter
sido de outra forma
o espaço é difícil para nós imaginar
outras formas por nós somos assim e
portanto não conseguimos pensar como é
que seria de outra forma e no caso eu é
trouxe exemplo das cores porque há uma
grande diversidade de dimensões digamos
cromáticas entre os bares mesmo entre
humanos é importante o que não é o caso
eu acredito no caso de imaginar a
dimensões espaciais ou seja nós somos
muito uniformes liriel todos nós
pensamos essencialmente três dimensões é
e nós precisamos de mais do que estas
três dimensões sociais nós estamos
habituados precisamos parar entre nós eu
eu para me identificar e para dizer onde
encostou eu preciso dizer tô nestas
jornadas fisicamente 3 fornada smas pois
precisa dizer para que lado eu estou
virado neste caso nesse caso ouvir a
platéia mas eu poderia estar deitado de
costas ou seja além da minha posição
espacial tem de identificar o outro tipo
de posições por exemplo a orientação
depois ainda têm de identificar em que a
altura do tempo apostou nessa posição
mais uma vez a uma dimensão linear e
podia continuar por aí fora
ou seja uma quantidade enorme de
informação e dimensões de certa forma
que eu tenho de indicar para localizar
nós humanos tendemos a separar estas
coisas tendemos a pensar que tem três
dimensões espaciais
tem uma questão de orientação pois tem
uma questão tempo e esperamos essas
coisas o que é compreensível porque
fisicamente certa forma o som de frente
matematicamente banho mas poderia não
ser assim
deixe-me tentar convencer disso imagine
uma pessoa que não tem as três dimensões
espaciais juntas mas tinha duas
dimensões espaciais essencialmente à sua
localização seguinte forma 1º de escola
que a sua título hoje tudo nos preocupa
citou mais alto ou mais baixo depois
eventualmente para que o alex ouvirá os
pormenores para sul
depois eventualmente tenha dimensão da
altura este seria provavelmente um ser
que nunca vou pôr preto base não ser que
tivesse vivido sempre um pano quem sabe
não saia por acaso vai ter aqui uma
pergunta quem sabe não animais pensam
assim não sai mas de certa forma
esperava duas dimensões espaciais tanto
a frente para trás da dimensão para cima
e para baixo
eventualmente ser só conseguiria
imaginar as férias até duas dimensões
porque não tinha o conceito das três
dimensões espaciais unificadas o então
vou dizendo a mostrar outro exemplo é
imaginem que nós éramos feitos de duas
partes estão pouco estranho mas imaginem
que seria possível
não estou não estou preocupado se seria
biologicamente aval à não esqueçam isso
mas a tanque de animais animais gordos
magros altos baixos - é porque não
existir um ser que é feito de duas
partes é imaginar que o cérebro de ser
edson portanto de certa forma o cérebro
também estavam à vontade do outro não
sei que organiza mas ninguém dá uma
forma está um jeitaço agora não é por
nós mesmos ficaram estado em casa na
itália trabalharam até podemos ir em
dias alternados limitado e o resultado e
amanhã vamos então eu quero ficar em
casa dormindo quando cortar e cortar na
horizontal ou na vertical de se decretar
na vertical não será uma vantagem mas
imaginem que é um ser assim mas o quer
que imaginem é que serviu assim possa
gil sempre foi assim
o cérebro deu está preparado por eu ser
assim
precisamos de três jornadas para
localizar mas este ser precisa de 63
para uma parte 3 pra outra
nós humanos tendemos a achar que o caiu
eu com as minhas três dimensões resolva
o problema do gauchão parta um à parte
de outro três dimensões são precisas
para determinar a posição de uma parta
23 para determinar a posição da outra e
portanto eu resolvo o problema mas o que
eu estou convencido e se um cérebro
tivesse evoluído diretamente reis com um
corpo com estas características teria
evoluído naturalmente pensar as suas
dimensões porto ponto está a matemática
é muito claro este ser fica bem
determinado quando eu indicar seis
coordenadas 3 com a 3par outros
provavelmente ser perceber as seis
dimensões
não sei se poderia chamar os especiais
mas eu teria uma ginástica mental para
pensar as seis dimensões provavelmente
conseguiria imaginar uma espera de
quatro de cinco de sair mas
provavelmente não conseguiria imaginar a
sétima provável - se eu fosse mesmo
assim estaria aqui hoje a discutir
porque nós não conseguimos ver a sete
menções era para concluir
eu diria que nós não conseguimos ver a
quatro dimensões
essencialmente porque somos assim com
muitas outras características como
secreta ou cometer duas orelhas já
pensaram que poderia ter quatro uma
virada para a frente ou para trás não é
o talvez uma só uma aqui por cima né
mas eu tenho duas e porque contém duas e
não tem quatro bem por por alguma razão
do ponto de vista evolutivo owa alguma
vantagem e winter estas duas muralhas
data localizar especialmente quando as
pessoas me falam ser o único som vem
ou seja houve alguma vantagem eu diria
com as três dimensões espaciais é
exatamente a mesma coisa ou alguma
vantagem para nós pensarmos a três
dimensões espaciais é vantagem
provavelmente é o fato do nosso do nosso
parceiro factory nacional e portanto é
natural facto nós pensarmos a três
dimensões mas poderia não ter sido assim
muito obrigado